maybe we can start with elaborating a
little bit more on this
prosecutor preacher politician uh rubric
that you've
set up here the original idea comes from
a colleague of mine phil tutlock
who's studied political psychology and
social psychology most of his career and
phil observed that in decision making in
judgment
we spend a lot of time thinking like
preachers prosecutors and politicians
and we're usually not aware of it when
we're doing it a preacher mindset is
essentially
believing that you've already seen the
light and now you have to go and
proselytize
to everybody else and get them on board
so you're
you've drunk the intellectual kool-aid
and now your job is to serve it
a prosecuting mindset is more about
proving everyone else wrong
and winning your side of the case and
then
a politician mindset is is really about
saying okay i've got some constituents
here
and i need to lobby for their buy-in i
want their support
and my big worry rich was when i learned
about this framework i thought okay
preaching and prosecuting stop those
stop you from thinking again
because if i know i'm right and i'm sure
you're wrong
i don't need to budge in any of my
opinions or
any of the knowledge that i i hold i
just need to convince you to do that
and in politician mode we see people
sounding a lot more flexible
but it's really just adjusting what they
say
to fit in it's not actually changing
what they believe internally and that
that's just basically flip-flopping
yeah i think i i fall mostly into the
the politicking camp as a really as a
i'm surprised to hear you say that
really why would you say that well i
would have guessed
just because of the way that you've
inspired so many people i would have
guessed that that preaching might be
the default of those three for you i
preaching is very uncomfortable for me i
i'm much more
interested in in approval and being
liked
to a default in in in a not so great way
like i've
really made major life decisions based
on approval
or doing this socially except i mean i
was a lawyer for over a decade
you know trying to jam a square peg into
a round hole for for way too long and
very reluctant to get out of it uh out
of you know fear of
social repercussions and familial
expectations and the like
and you know i i i i would sit
in depositions or in hearings
and just see the gray and everything and
just felt like i'm a really bad
advocate because i i really want to
appreciate the nuance in all of this and
can't we just all get along
like i'm conflict-averse i'm a
people-pleaser
and you know i host these podcasts and i
want to be challenging in the
conversations but also
i only have the people on that i respect
and admire so
i'm sitting here you know and if i'm
being honest it's like i want adam to
like me i want him to respect me
you know that's that's like you know
just calling myself out
in a vulnerable way over like my own
motivations
and so i i spent a lot of time thinking
about that but i also
i want to throw like a little bit of a
test case out out to you
um so i've been vegan for
about 14 years now and
i guess for better or worse part that's
part of my
identity and i spent a lot of time
thinking about
how i um how i
you know embody that ethos how i carry
that message
how i advocate you know for something
that i believe in
and you know i've realized that for my
own personal
you know makeup i don't feel
uh it doesn't feel natural to me to be a
preacher about it
i'm not interested in taking other
people's inventory and criticizing
their decisions i don't think it's
effective
and i kind of settled into
a mode that's a little bit outside of
your paradigm which is this idea of
of of being kind of a lighthouse like if
i
live my life well and equip myself as an
athlete
as uh you know somebody who is excelling
intellectually mentally
emotionally and just living well it acts
more like
a magnet or a tractor beam
that will bring the receptive audience
to me who might be willing or interested
to hear about it and
it also goes back to 12 step and how i
got sober and the tools that i learned
in the program which are all about not
giving advice but just sharing your
experience and so i'm curious about how
that fits into how you think about these
ideas of
of influencing people and getting people
to kind of open up their minds and
consider different
concepts wow i think that's brilliant
i i i'm kicking myself now because if we
had had this conversation a year ago
i would have written that in to think
again oh well now i'm bummed
i i wish i'd met you earlier it's i it's
not my it's not my
idea though but it's just something that
seems to work better than any of these
other three options although it doesn't
start with a p
yeah yeah it's it's not alliterative
and i no i think i think you articulated
it
so beautifully though it's
there's there's a lot to react to there
so i want to i want to double click on a
few things you said let's just start
with the lighthouse idea
i think that that might be the most
compelling work around
that i've i don't even want to call it a
workaround that's i think that's not
doing justice to it
it's the most compelling solution i can
think of to
the tension between what i guess was my
preferred alternative to preaching
prosecuting and politicking which is
thinking like a scientist and
the need if you want to influence people
in the world to do some preaching
and i've i've always been uncomfortable
with that tension because so
i guess i should take a step back and
just say thinking like a scientist is
is what i would love for more people to
do more often and i don't mean you have
to go and
wear a white coat all the time or carry
around test tubes
or even own a microscope right what i
mean is that
the just the broadest idea of of science
is the pursuit of knowledge and truth
and if your identity is anchored in
being a scientist it means that
you don't have to stick to a certain set
of beliefs at any one time
you want to find out what's going to be
effective or
what the right way is to live your
values and that means
when you form an opinion it's a
hypothesis you can go out and test it
you can observe you can interact you can
run experiments
and the hope is that you're as excited
to find out that you were wrong as you
are to prove that you were right because
either way
uh you've you know you've you've
potentially learned something and i
would argue even you learn more when you
discover that
your hypothesis was false then when then
when you validate it
and and yet phil tutlock when
when i talked to him first about this
framework saying okay
i i want everyone to think more like
scientists he said well
yeah but sometimes you have to talk much
more like a preacher in order to be
heard
yeah you know just look at any pundit on
tv
or any leader who gives an inspiring
speech
and i've never liked that as as
something that you have to do
and i think you you just gave an
alternative which is to say okay i can
think like a scientist
i can test in my own life whether i'm
gonna be
i'm gonna be at my best in you know in
an ironman
when when i go vegan right that's an
experiment you ran
and then once i do that if i'm willing
to share what i've learned from that and
i talk about that publicly
i don't have to tell other people to do
it i don't have to preach about it
i'm just i'm just telling my story and
that will draw people to me i think
that i just think that's ingenious well
it's effective it seems to be more
effective and
i think it's all you know a sort of
corollary to that for me is
is a more kind of buddhist or eastern
philosophical perspective on this which
is that i'm not attached
to whether or not i'm convincing anybody
to change
like i'm just i'm carrying this certain
vibration
i'm happy to talk about issues that i
care about
if you approach me or you're interested
but i'm not
interested in proselytizing i'm
interested in in you know living my best
life and it's this idea of attraction
rather than promotion which is
core to the whole 12-step philosophy
yes and it's it's so consistent with his
stance of motivational interviewing
which is i'm not here to force you to
change i'm here to
help you if i can uncover your own
motivation for change
but that's up to you and i think the
person on the receiving end of it
feels the difference between somebody
who is
really wed to an outcome versus somebody
who's like hey i'm just telling you this
like
it's your business what you do with this
information or not
it's such a paradox because
my biggest advice is going into
prosecutor mode it just
i think the cartoon that could be my
life story is the one where
uh this guy's sitting at a computer and
his wife says what's wrong and he says
someone is wrong on the internet you're
right yeah yeah and he can't sleep
that's me it's just as some as
as a social scientist when somebody
believes something that
goes against the weight of the evidence
i think i felt for a long time like it
was my moral responsibility to try to
correct them
right and not only was that
way too high and mighty of me and
self-righteous it also didn't work
to your point about effectiveness have
you i don't i don't see you
trolling people on twitter though like
you don't get involved in that kind of
stuff
no i but i have i've written some
articles
that i think led people to really
misjudge me
as you know as being actually a close
colleague of mine uh
one of the people who i consider part of
my challenge network not not my support
network
one of my most thoughtful critics said
to me do you want to spend your career
being a professional debunker
right i said no i want to i want to
build ideas up not tear them down but i
also believe that if somebody is selling
snake oil that you know we we should
make the world aware of that and that
that tension has
been really tricky for me but i think
this idea of being a lighthouse and
saying look here's my analysis of the
evidence and here's my experience
applying it
what do you make of that the irony in it
for me is
i it really invalidates one of my core
beliefs which is when you have a goal
you should work as hard as you can to
achieve it and in this case it is very
buddhist like you said
letting go of the goal a little bit and
saying look i my
my mission here is not to persuade it's
to share it's to teach it's to learn
that actually makes me more persuasive
precisely because i'm not trying to be
persuasive
yeah well i think it gets into the
mysteries of
of the of the human mind in the sense
that
what wins the day isn't necessarily the
most
sound proof logical argument uh
more often than not at least in my own
experience and i'm curious what you make
of this
it's if you can if you can really
emotionally connect with the person that
you're talking to and engender some
level of trust
which has nothing to do with logic that
ultimately can be
the lever that moves the needle more
than you know
the you know the facts of the case or
the scientific aspects of whatever it is
that you're discussing
i mean that's certainly consistent with
my read of the data it's stunning to me
that when i think about these
experiments that corinne bendurski has
run for example that just saying to
somebody who has a different opinion
than you
i respect people who have clear
principles
is enough to reduce animosity and
lead to more openness in a conversation
it's one of the simplest demonstrations
of your point and yet it makes me think
that maybe what what you sort of
sheepishly said
is you know more of a politician
sometimes than i would like to be
is an advantage because it leads you to
build that connection
and that trust
[Music]
you